okay so we're doing something now we've
never really done before comedy yeah
there's kind of two times we review a
movie one is when we write it we put it
into a script then but the first time is
when we watch it we like to call the
mst3k yeah it's it's kinda like an at4
UK where we don't really watch and then
form our opinions you know after I mean
we do that too but we sort of shout
jokes and thought these are our opinions
during yeah we kind of say what we think
of it as we're watching it so you know
we can't say good things we say bad
things we shout jokes and we start right
down the best notes and today we are
watching Balto we actually do critique
it while watching it and this just can't
be service short compilation of our
first reaction to seeing the film I
haven't seen it he has uh it's
apparently good but we both feel there's
this stuff we can talk about we can make
fun of it computer comedy they take
liberties yeah so we're going to try
this out see the work just can put our
best comments in there and just clipping
together so well that's it here we go
Universal Pictures presents what will
get wiped out by Toy Story in the same
week that's so long since my last
kidnapping what's your name how many
kids do you think we're totally confused
in the first like minute just like this
is the cartoon or is on the car down way
no no this is a live-action short that
comes before the cartoon it was not a
hobby 30 world
that's where fall so one time today I'm
going to take a wild guess and say the
black dog is the bad guy right okay what
was that a minute why can't the Padres
and Phantom Menace be that shatter ego
and Anakin wins moving on to a better
story
hi MA good yeah no no he's Russian now
oh good that's Russian accent sense and
in the gate I had a dog one that liked
bacon so that two degrees of Kevin Bacon
[Music]
yeah when you're gonna get sick damn
send plot need illness stop moving
getting zone
suggest children in peril stop I gotta
give that character cry like every
drawing and frame is like just dripping
evil I know like no person would just go
hide you decided no we're just gonna
make this guy here even Lord I'd imagine
- my teeth tonight a normal person
coughing ha ha ha ha
can you imagine boarding the handi meal
I like a happy meal this is every
Republican politician around Trump right
now yeah that was great
your Perryville we love it we love it
see the look yeah the little ones McCain
and then Susie leaves is like god I hate
that guy hate them so much this totally
it I look down for a second what was
that but uh let me just do my trailer
Podolia trailer pose because of he's
like ha ha like photo
honestly I'd say about 50% of film
trailer yeah yeah alright hey I had a
whole routine itis unplanned come on
this one sees me I haven't remitted
renovate to that we were supposed to
have song you know it's a little by the
numbers but man there is a lot of
passion into the problem with this it's
a good story and it's the by the numbers
own ones that actually drag it down yeah
this would be a great film based on a
true story
put that on Balto did not sneak in to
hospital and cannot understand England
was Alaska TV I think it still is
Alaskan TV he even carries sausages evil
hangover what well he is named Steve yes
this is a brilliant idea
let's tile these dogs out before we send
them on a missions and go
at the antitoxin are you laughing at the
giant kid ha finally yeah I love this
holy shit yeah and there's a Tiny Tim
and little mad girl and coffee
fuck why those bears not even ed duck I
am ruining your movie I'm so sorry I'm
outside here
I got I am out of this I'm not coming
back sorry I do you kind of feel I
ruined your chance to Academy Award
College ah what a background work
I mean no that sounds gorgeous yeah like
this one was way better than it had any
right to be
those are two bears versus one you could
look at the colors in the C note yeah
it's a stylized this fuck I love it you
miss U's Mike her office yeah Bridget
Fonda you know it's in the sound book
like really like that's not a good leave
out it oh alright little red on the
Gabino they're fucking the bassist me I
love these fucking dogs
by the way big balls oh thanks for
saving us right right Oh God
how is this guy not a more emotional
endeavor list literally he's like fuck
dying children bad dog bad dog
yeah I think the movie gravity was nicer
to it the main character even his
shaking is evil honey when you get older
remember everything that you're not
seeing the real story was just because I
made in bed and I caught it I laid in
bed and I called dammit I figured it out
that's what's going on
grandma's telling those boring ass
historically accurate version of the
story and the kids making this up in
earnest ha moto you must take your place
so what a mean grandma I don't know
bullshit Crayola I love it I feel like
that guy but maybe front row is like a
given yeah oh nothing
and then the gods knees and there is an
ambulance which is called a boobie chick
shit shit shit and shit if I was a kid I
was just imagine God with darts
constantly throwing a messes dog and I
don't know where a meteor hits him but
it was too late ah and who are you
guerrilla I don't know and then I die
[Laughter]
that was like dogs wrenching we rub
noses Avery I did like it but the one
thing it does bother me they just
totally cut a dialogue you know and it's
just now this shit happens now this
should happen and it just kind of they
get there and that's it it just stops
it's like yeah there's like the wolf's
prejudice whatever and that's kind of
resolved but it's like I don't know I
feel like there's no there wasn't like
much of an epilogue there wasn't much of
a climax it was long as it just stopped
overall it's a really solid spell it is
it's one of it's a good film it's not
great oh yeah all the reasons you know
yeah like I said this is our first time
trying this let us know if you want to
see more more than where to later the
TV's here in the camera series for the
most part just look at the TV but I mean
what we're addressing the people at home
you know it will looks great to them so
yeah that's kind of what it's like
watching uh watching these movies on the
first time and then we're going to take
you know server cruises themselves and
enter it into a script turn it into a
nostalgic reg video because again that
Sora helps you know get the point of
view across in different ways through
comedy through visuals through character
songs all that kind of stuff so yeah
let's know if you want to see more of
these just sort of a general idea of
what the critiquing process is like for
us so uh that's about itamae we'll see
you next time